bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alexis blanc comment est
ce que vous expliquez que ce mouvement
de contestation perdure en plein été
c'est vrai que c'est inédit de voir un
mouvement de contestation qui continue à
de grossir au plein coeur de l'été je
crois que ça s'explique tout simplement
parce que les français n'ont pas
confiance dans la parole du gouvernement
et de ses ministres qui ont dit tout et
son contraire depuis mars 2020 donc
difficile de comprendre la façon qu'ils
sont contraints et puis difficile
d'accepter aussi se passe sanitaire qui
n'a rien de sanitaire puisque j'apprends
aujourd'hui par exemple que dans
l'eurostar il n'est pas demandé et la
sncf n'a pas su répondre ce matin
pourquoi il n'était pas demandée donc
voila voila un peu le n'importe quoi qui
est en cours on a vu ces scènes aussi de
gens qui voulaient rentrer dans des
supermarchés faire leurs courses est
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le passe ou les gens bien sûr
qu'il y avait des soucis pour accéder à
l'hôpital donc on est dans quelque chose
qui est inacceptable de leur dénier
acceptable qui n'a rien de sanitaires
encore une fois qui est de l'ordre de la
contrainte à la fois fait par emmanuel
macron pour pousser les gens la
vaccination parce que il ne veut pas
rendre la vaccination obligatoire sans
doute ne peut le petit ne pas le faire
puisque les autorisations de mise sur le
marché sont pour le moment pas papa
pérenne donc on a vraiment là quelque
chose de l'ordre du temps long
évidemment en août le mouvement et
historique à impressionnant à la rentrée
ça risque d'être plus et c'est une
fronde qui veut dire non à ce monde
qu'on nous propose deux contrôles
permanents soit disant pour notre santé
alors que on voit bien que les mesures
sanitaires ne sont pas là ne suivent pas
il y a des plans blancs qui sont
déclenchées dans les hôpitaux parce que
les soignants se sont mis en congé
maladie parce qu'ils n'en peuvent plus
les urgentistes sonné l'alarmé il y a
deux ans de ça avant la crise du
coronavirus ils n'étaient pas entendues
et nacre on leur disait qu'il ne voulait
pas faire de la dette aujourd'hui la
dette qu'ovide elle et sarah mineuse on
ne sait pas comment va la rembourser et
au dessus de cette dette coville se
profile une crise économique avec des
secteurs entiers qui vont fermer ou des
gens qui vont
sur une très mauvaise alexis blanc on va
essayer de rejoindre on va essayer de
vous retrouver dans quelques instants
jacques myard
maquereau a défendu le pass and i ter en
expliquant que c'était cela ou la
fermeture du pays est ce que c'est un
argument qui justifie la mesure
c'est lorsque vous relisez la décision
du conseil constitutionnel et que vous
la regardez scrupuleusement vous
apercevez que healy a pratiquement 60
alinéa qui sont consacrés à l'analyse du
pass sanitaires et qu'en réalité le
conseil constitutionnel a considéré que
le pass and i ter était effectivement
quelque chose
d'anti libertés publiques et sans doute
sur le fond une
un accro à la constitution mais il la
banalité parce qu'il est limitée dans le
temps et donc
nos concitoyens ont parfaitement compris
qu'ils avaient aussi de ce côté là des
arguments forts au nom des libertés
publiques mais ces manifestations en
réalité elles sont des résultats d'un
profond amalgame à l'égard contre le
gouvernement et je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour dire qu'à la rentrée cela
risque de prendre une autre ampleur
contre le gouvernement il y à une sorte
d' amalgame générale il y a le pas
salutaire il y à l'insécurité il y a les
craintes en matière de rentrée pour les
enfants bref on est dans un état non pas
de
de révolution mais d'une révolte et
d'une opposition frontale au
gouvernement alors ce n'est certes pas
la majorité mais je suis convaincu que
nous allons avoir une rentrée assez
chaude qui peut dériver et mettre en
péril la sérénité et puis surtout à l'
approche des élections suivez mon regard
il est évident que cela va sans doute
s'amplifier
maintenant sur le fond personnellement
je suis vacciné et je crois que la
vaccination est la seule solution
mais on a affaire aussi un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens qui sont dans
une sorte d' irrationnelles
il se pose des questions ce qui est
légitime et là le gouvernement a fait
une faute c'est que dans un premier
temps il les à morigéner il les a tancé
et il ne s'est pas chez le ministre
beran
à un moment a dit ras le bol ça suffit
c'est pas comme ça qu'on parle aux
français surtout lorsque vous avez un
peuple qui a l'habitude de de résister
non seulement à lompret à l'oppression
nous ne sommes pas dans une dictature
mais qui a un côté fraudeurs qui est
nous sommes des gaulois réfractaires et
nous l'exprimons avec force donc ces
manifestations certes aujourd'hui il ya
un peu moins de monde mais on voit très
bien que sa jeunesse c'est un très bon
ça vient du fond de de l'opinion
publique et que la rentrée risque d'être
chaude très chaude on parle beaucoup
alexis poulains de ce mouvement de
protestation hétéroclite
finalement le dénominateur commun à tous
les manifestants c'est cette défiance à
l'égard d' emmanuel macron
je crois que ça va au delà de la
personne des mails macron il ya un
attachement finalement à une certaine
idée de la france de la république
française ces valeurs liberté égalité
fraternité
dans ce passé ni terre c'est trois
valeurs sont totalement bafoués floués
et avec une certaine légèreté de la part
des mâles bacon qui fait des annonces en
tee shirt depuis le fort de brégançon
qui est très content de son annonce du
12 juillet clinique continue comme ça à
à rudoyer les français c'est ce qu'il
fait de mieux et indique qu'il peut
insulter france et à l'étranger ils en
profitent et puis il rentre ai dit vous
n'avez rien compris il faut mais coup de
théâtre il faut obéir il n'est pas
question de venir les questions de
comprendre les questions d'avoir
confiance le gouverner c'est pas à
contraindre de manière perpétuelle là on
est dans autre chose la république elle
demande une responsabilité de chacun
bien sûr et chacun est conscient de ses
droits et de ses devoirs
demandez aux gens d'avoir de moins en
moins de droits et de plus en plus de
devoir c'est pas une bonne équation
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
parce que les citoyens qui manifestent
aujourd'hui un veulent un débat on n'a
pas vu de débats à l'assemblée nationale
ce qui s'est passé sur le pass sanitaire
ça a été un débat bâclé qui était très
pid avant les vacances parlementaires
pour que ça puisse rentrer dans les
clous comme le voulait le maquereau
qu'il peut tout de manière isolée en
conseil de défense là on est très loin
d'une gouvernance démocratique d'une
gouvernance républicaine capelle les
français qui sont dans la rue de leurs
voeux qui voudraient davantage de
raisons on est dedans
on est on est dans quelque chose loin à
la fois de l'objectif sanitaire qui est
imposée est loin de la raison qui est
celle du débat démocratique et mâcon dit
tout et son contraire et sans rajouter
de l'huile sur le feu donc au delà de la
personne des mâles mâcon je crois que tu
une idée aussi une défense de la
personne humaine de du citoyen français
de la valeur de cette citoyenneté et des
valeurs de ce pays qu'est la france qui
sont souvent bafoués par par emmanuel
macron alors qu'il est censé être le
garant des institutions je crois que
c'est là que cette fronde peut s'ancrer
dans le temps long parce qu'on voit bien
que le mouvement est à partisans il est
familiale vous avez tous les âges qui se
rencontrent et vous avez des personnes
vaccinées qui ne sont pas le contre la
vaccination qui sont dans ce mouvement
parce qu'ils refusent cette logique de
passes sanitaire cette logique de
contrôle c'est elle qui de secours rien
de mes droits citoyens numéro 2 de grade
dans la citoyenneté qui profile un
finalement une que nous ne voulons pas
ici que les choses soient claires et je
crois que c'est ce que révèle mâcon doit
entendre puisque nous sommes en plus
dans une année électorale il se pourrait
que les surprises soit encore plus
grande que celle de sa candidature en
2017 jacques myard c'est un problème de
communication politique cette opposition
entre les vacciner les non vaccinés ce
qu'elles pèsent aujourd'hui sur le
message sanitaire
alors vous savez je veux dire une chose
je crois qu'il ne faut pas analyser ces
mouvements comme étant uniquement une
question de passes sanitaires sur lequel
personnellement je pense que c'est pas
la meilleure des solutions et que c'est
une atteinte aux libertés publiques
qu'on le veuille ou non même si ce sera
limité dans le temps au 15 novembre
mais en réalité on a ici un amalgame et
les conséquences directes de ce que je
dirais le mépris perçue par les français
du président de la république
les petites phrases
les incohérences les changements de pied
on est nous dit on parlait plus de
souveraineté mais on parlait de
mondialisation heureuse et tout d'un
coup on revient à la souveraineté
française voire européenne
donc on a une incohérence globale et
tout ça mis bout-à-bout abouti à un
projet non seulement des manuels macro
mais de l'ensemble de l'équipe
gouvernementale
qui n'existe d'ailleurs pas ils ont été
sanctionnés aux dernières élections
régionales
et bien sûr un peu encore parce qu'il ne
compte pas
mâcon jupiter reste mâcon jupiter et ça
ça agace profondément les français qui
veulent que les les corps intermédiaires
que l'assemblée nationale joue son rôle
on sait très bien on a une assemblée
nationale hologramme qui n'existe pas
donc le roi est nu le roi est seul et
toutes ces manifestations aujourd'hui
traduit un rejet de mâcon jupiter et de
tous ceux qui l'accompagnent
donc je crois qu si ça continue on va
avoir une sorte de crise de régime et
bien sûr ce sera sanctionnée par les
élections présidentielles qui ne sont
pas encore joué tant s'en faut et on
verra quels sont les candidats mais ça
va se décanter assez rapidement pour des
raisons de calendrier évidente alors on
le voit depuis plusieurs semaines ces
manifestations on est parfois c'est le
cas aujourd'hui on est parfois par les
gilet jaune et ce qu'ils trouvent alexis
poule en un nouveau souffle avec avec
cette contestation contrôlent pas
salutaire est ce que pour reprendre les
propos de jacques myard vous vous
attendez à une rentrée chaude
oui oui complètement je crois que il
avait d'ailleurs tenu la flamme c'est
gilet jaune puisqu'il continuer de
manifester moins nombreux chaque samedi
mais il était là présent même si ce
mouvement a montré une contestation déjà
à l'époque un sur la façon dont on
traitait le français moyen le français
lambert dont vous êtes des fumeurs de
clubs qui roulent au diesel maintenant
il faut payer une taxe carbone et puis
c'est comme ça non c'est pas comme ça je
crois qu'il faut justement dans une
démocratie de la vie des autres et ce
mouvement de g je ne portais des
aspirations démocratiques de démocratie
directe le risque est bien d'autres
choses et une envie de politique
autrement de république autrement avec
ces quelques doléances qui ont été
enterrés au sous sol de la bibliothèque
nationale de france et ce grand débat
qui a été phagocyté par emmanuel macron
qui en a fait une campagne pour les
élections européennes où il a pris la
parole seul au milieu d'un casting de
deux militants la république en marche
donc c'est scandaleux aujourd'hui on
voit bien que la colère qui gronde ne
s'est jamais éteinte le prix de
l'essence est encore plus haut que ce
qu'ils étaient lors des styles et les
jaunes et derrière au delà des légendes
vous avez maintenant des gens qui
manifestent pour la première fois de
leur vie et retraités des mères de
famille de n'importe qui qui se rend
compte que maintenant la politique c'est
à la rue parce que emmanuel macron en
jupiter quel pied parce qu'il a
finalement saper les piliers de la
république préfère avoir cette
confrontation avec la russe est beaucoup
plus facile de dire peu sont dangereux
eux ce sont des séditieux c'était ce que
disait castaner ministre de l'intérieur
lorsqu'il est borgniet à tour de bras
les manifestants gilet jaune ça n'a
choqué personne à l'époque nous ça nous
a choqués et aujourd'hui on voit que la
même rhétorique et est en place il
sentit scénith leurs slogans sont
dangereux ils sont des séditieux
ya un problème c'est que ces
manifestants ils ne sont nourris
lorsqu'un toute la violence d'état ne
veut pas se mettre en branle comme ça a
été le cas pour les gilet jaune et il ya
un bug dans la main au
budget de prendre en compte ces
manifestants qui sont des français moyen
des familles de deux comme je disais de
tous les âges et égyptiens il ya quelque
chose qui pourrait de finalement arrivés
vers un mouvement populiste populaire
peut-être un nouveau mouvement politique
qui va à l'encontre de du plan de site
macron d'être ce dirigeant de la raison
celui qui incarne la raison aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que c'est lui qui a
perdu la raison est que ceux qui sont
dans la rue sont là pour le ramener sur
terre et dire on ne peut pas continuer
avec des lois liberticides un régime
d'exception et des conseils de
défenseurs sécuritaire ce n'est pas ça
la république
il faut pas arrêter et et je crois que
c'est illusoire aussi de quoi se passe
est limitée dans le temps quand on voit
que certains
restaurateurs ou commerçants s'équipe
d'un klaxon je crois que la carte d'un
claquement de doigts décidé que l'état
d'urgence est
la dernière fois jacques myard est ce
qui vous dirait qu'il ya une volonté
assumée la part du chef de l'état de
marginaliser une partie de la population
en l'occurrence les non-vaccinés c'est
une stratégie que vous diriez perdante
et ce sera le mot de la fin
je suis intimement convaincu que
l'attitude du gouvernement des manuels
d'accrocs en particulier ne fait
qu'attiser je dirais ce mouvement de
révolte ne parle pas de révolution mais
il est évident qu'il ya un fonds fort de
gilet jaune actuellement qui défilent ce
qui est certain c'est qu'on ne parle pas
aux français sur un ton méprisant et on
ne peut pas marginaliser ce mouvement au
contraire on doit on doit essayer de
recréer la confiance
or aujourd'hui cette confiance n'existe
plus et c'est ça le problème parce que
il bien sûr il ya peut-être moins de
gens aujourd'hui dans la rue mais quand
vous regardez les sondages vous avez en
pratiquement 40 consent des français qui
approuvent ses mouvements et donc c'est
ça le problème gouverner ce n'est pas je
dirais utilisait la vindicte gouverner
s'est créé le rassemblement et
apparaître comme le chef d'al turrel des
français qui vont leur montrer la bois
alors montrer qu'il ya une solution à
nos difficultés
à mon avis bien sûr la vaccination est
incontournable mais il demeure pas moins
que il faut de la pédagogie toujours la
pédagogie et surtout pas de mépris donc
tout ce kit sera qui viendra du
gouvernement et du président de la
république en particulier et qui montera
du doigt je dirais ces mouvements est
vouée à l'échec et ne fera qu'amplifier
la la je dirais le rejet même
des institutions et du président de la
république merci beaucoup jacques myard
mer les républicains maisons laffitte à
merci à vous avec six poulains vitoria
liste rmf